a continuación se muestra la función fx
en tres formas equivalentes selecciona
la forma que más fácilmente revela la
intersección de la gráfica de igual
fx con el eje y así que recordemos un
poco si tengo por aquí la gráfica de
igual
fx déjame hacerla por aquí esta va a ser
la gráfica de james igual a efe de x y
observamos que es una función cuadrática
déjame ver es una función cuadrática por
lo tanto se va a ver como una parábola y
de hecho es una palabra que abre hacia
arriba así que se va a ver más o menos
así voy a tener por aquí a mí para
hablar que abre hacia arriba y yo sé que
es una palabra que abre ser iván porque
el coeficiente que está al lado de la
equis cuadrada es positivo lo que nos
está diciendo que tenemos una palabra
que abre hacia arriba entonces nos
preguntan dónde inter secamos con el eje
de leyes
justo por aquí eso quiere decir que
estamos diciendo hey cuál es el valor de
que cuando x vale 0 es justo lo que
nosotros buscamos y bueno esto se va a
reducir a qué tan rápido podemos evaluar
la función en cero
cuánto vale f x cuando x es igual a cero
y como estas tres opciones son formas
equivalentes entonces la función f está
dada en tres diferentes formas en esta o
en esta o en esta eso quiere decir que
deberíamos de ser capaces de manipular
algebraica mente cada una de estas para
obtener las otras dos
ahora bien veamos si quiero evaluar efe
de cero en mi primera opción
bueno aquí me quedaría a cero este no
puede sustituir por cero y me quedarían
seis elevado al cuadrado
eso por tres y después restarle 75 lo
cual se puede hacer se puede calcular
pero supongo que hay una forma más fácil
para encontrar cuánto vale
efe de cero
así que en definitiva esta no es la
opción correcta en nuestra segunda
opción buena observa si sustituyó a x x
0 esto se va esto se va y me quedaría la
multiplicación de 3 por 1 por 11 lo cual
parece ser más rápido que la opción
número uno pero tampoco creo que sea la
opción correcta porque al final estamos
haciendo un cierto cálculo la
multiplicación de 3 por 11 sin embargo
en nuestra última opción en esta de aquí
que por cierto se le conoce como la
forma estándar déjame escribirlo si
sustituyó el valor de x por 0 este
término se va este término se va y
simplemente me quedo con 33 entonces
esta es la forma estándar la forma
estándar fue por mucho la más fácil para
saber dónde estamos intersectando me
aleje de las 10 voy a tachar esta porque
fue la forma más fácil para ver donde
encontramos la intersección con el eje y
y después nos dice cuál es intersección
de efe con el eje y bueno la
intersección con el eje y es cero
como 33 déjame ponerlo 33 ahora te voy a
hacer un consejo para que tengas
precaución a veces deberían de ver lo
que se le conoce como la forma vértice
que es esta que tenemos aquí es más
déjame anotarlo la forma vértice está
como vamos a ver en el siguiente
ejercicio en la forma más fácil para
averiguar cuál es el vértice de mi
parábola sin embargo hay que tener
cuidado porque tal vez esté menos 75 se
parezca a este 33 porque son términos
libres y entonces éste es tentado a
decir si quiero saber cuánto es
efe de 0 bueno canceló todo esto que
tengo aquí y me quedo simplemente con el
menos 75 pero qué creés hay que ser muy
cuidadosos aquí porque eso no es cierto
cuando x vale 0 solamente esto de aquí
es lo que vale 0 como vimos lo podemos
cancelar y me quedo adentro del
paréntesis con el 6 en este
y como dije tendremos 6 al cuadrado por
3 y a eso habrá que quitarle 75 así que
en definitiva
efe de 0 no es menos 75 y es por eso que
quería decirte que tengas mucho cuidado
con esta forma vértice y bueno justo por
esto la mejor forma es la forma estándar
para resolver este primer problema es
por eso que elegimos esta opción y no la
forma beltzer de la forma factorizar
déjame escribir que esta es la forma
factorizar que como te puedes imaginar
sirve bastante bien para encontrar los
ceros de la función así que bueno
hagamos otro ejemplo y para eso déjame
quitar este problema que tengo aquí y
ahora vamos a trabajar con este que dice
a continuación se muestran la función mx
ahora tengo la función mx en tres formas
equivalentes selecciona la forma que más
fácilmente revela el vértice de la
gráfica y igual
x y observa esta vez estamos buscando el
vértice y bueno justamente hace rato
estábamos diciendo que esta era la forma
vértice y porque es la forma verse bueno
porque podemos obtener de una manera
sencilla el bet sep y eso va a ser
cuando esta parte de aquí está parte de
aquí sea igual a 0 y como se eso bueno
lo que pasa es que te tienes que
acostumbrar a esta forma vértice y
después vas a ver todo mucho más claro y
va a ser más natural para ti
en este caso observa tenemos una
parábola que abre hacia arriba se ve más
o menos así una parábola que abra hacia
arriba y por lo tanto albert se observa
es el punto mínimo estamos buscando
ahora este punto mínimo y como pueden
ver aquí x menos 1 al cuadrado siempre
te va a dar algo mayor o igual a 0
siempre va a ser positivo o lo menos que
puede valer es 0 y si después lo
multiplicas por un 4 se va a mantener
positivo ahora como este es un punto
mínimo observa que cualquier cosa
que le sumes a 36 me va a dar un punto
más alto porque menos 36 más algo
positivo siempre va a ser más grande que
menos 36 y queremos el valor mínimo
entonces si el vértice es este el punto
de aquí nuestro punto mínimo nosotros
vamos a estar interesados en cuando en
esta parte de eclip es igual a cero y
esto es igual a cero cuando el gesto más
valor de uno cierto uno menos 10 al
cuadrado es 0 por 40 y entonces
solamente me quedo con el valor mínimo
de menos 36 y por lo tanto ya puedo
decir que el vértice va a ser el punto 1
coma y bueno m de uno como ya vimos es
menos 36 entonces menos 36 este es ni
vértice y todo esto lo estamos viendo
gracias a la forma vértice esta es la
forma más sencilla para poder ver dónde
encontramos el vértice y es que observa
estas otras dos también nos pueden decir
dónde encontrar el vértice pero es un
poco más difícil de hecho la más difícil
es esta
estándar ya que aquí lo que aconsejaría
es primero completar el cuadrado y
realizar otras técnicas para que podamos
llegar a la forma factor izada y ya que
estemos en la forma factor izada
encontremos los ceros de esta parábola
me van a quedar dos puntos que son las
intersecciones con el eje x y ya que
tenemos estas intersecciones entonces
buscar el punto medio entre ellas dos
que va a ser el punto equidistante a
estas dos raíces y después tomar la
coordenada x de ese punto medium y
buscar el vértice pero observa en
definitiva esa es la forma más fácil
para encontrar el vértice así que cuál
es el vértice bueno el vértice toma como
coordenadas 1 coma menos 36 de lujo y ya
sabemos que es un mínimo entonces lo voy
a tachar y qué te parece si hacemos un
último problema para esto voy a quitar
esta pantalla y vamos a traer el
siguiente problema
qué es este de aquí dice a continuación
se muestra la función gdx ahora vamos a
trabajar con una función llamada gdx en
tres formas equivalentes selecciona la
forma que más fácilmente revela los
ceros
ahora estoy buscando los ceros o las
raíces de esta función de x así que una
vez más cuando estamos hablando de ceros
o raíces
si tenemos este como el eje x entonces
al ver una parábola que abra hacia
arriba se ve más o menos así y las
raíces o los ceros son los valores de x
que hacen a esta función igual a cero
son los valores de x que nos dan las
intersecciones en x podrías verlo así
entonces cuál de estas formas es más
fácil para encontrar cuando la función
es igual a cero
bueno pues podrías expandir estas dos y
después buscar cuando esta función es
igual a cero pero
la más fácil para identificar los ceros
es la forma factor izada que es esta que
tenemos aquí esta de aquí porque es muy
fácil encontrar de aquí cuando esta
función es cero si nos tomamos lo que
está dentro de este paréntesis igual a
cero o lo que está dentro de este otro
paréntesis igual a cero y observa aquí
si x toma el valor de menos uno entonces
este paréntesis sea cero o en su dado
caso si tomamos a x con el valor de
menos 7 porque entonces este segundo
paréntesis se hace igual a 0 y al tomar
el valor de x igual a menos 1 o el valor
de x igual a menos 7 entonces toda esta
expresión se hace igual a cero así que
esta forma factor izada es la forma más
fácil y más rápida para poder encontrar
los ceros de una función y es que
observa si nos fijamos en esta primera
tenemos la forma a ver si podemos
encontrar los ceros si hacemos menos dos
que multiplican
4 esto elevado al cuadrado más 18 esto
igual a 0 y se nota que es la que tiene
más trabajo para encontrar los ceros así
que si podemos encontrar los ceros pero
yo la descartaría como la forma más
rápida para encontrar lo que buscamos y
esta tercera opción la forma estándar
bueno lo que yo haría es lo que se me
ocurre es factorizar para llegar a la
forma factor izada y así poder encontrar
los ceros por lo tanto tendría que
trabajarla un poco más para llegar a lo
que ya tenemos en la forma factor izada
y por lo tanto tampoco es la respuesta
correcta porque es más trabajo que lo
que obtuvimos en esta segunda opción así
que en definitiva la forma factor izada
es la mejor opción y después me
preguntan cuál sería uno de los ceros
deje de x bueno ya vimos que tenemos
estos dos ceros entonces puede hacer el
valor de x igual a menos uno o también
podrías escribir el valor de x igual a
menos 7